pas d'animaux encore donc Charlotte
Gagnon ne sait plus à quel saint se
vouer pour trouver d'ici le premier
juillet un logement où elle pourra
emménager avec son petit Milou après
trois mois de recherche des tonnes
d'annonces consultés la liste des
propriétaires avec qui elle a pu entrer
en contact et mince il y a beaucoup de
propriétaires qui dans leur poste disons
sur Facebook ou sur Kijiji 10 déjà qui
ne veulent pas d'animaux et la crise du
logement n'est donc rien sa situation et
on devrait jamais devoir abandonner qui
que ce soit pour se loger
personne ne devrait justement avoir à
faire ce choix quoi Québec solidaire
va déposer un projet de loi qui va
permettre les animaux de compagnie dans
tous les logements du Québec le projet
de loi sera déposé d'ici la fin de la
session parlementaire avec deux
objectifs diminuer le nombre d'abandon
d'animaux Québec et améliorer la santé
mentale des personnes concernées sans
entraîner de dépenses publiques croix
Québec solidaire
plus de la moitié des ménages québécois
héberge un chien ou un chat selon
l'Association des médecins vétérinaires
ce qui met davantage de pression sur les
organismes de protection des animaux dès
que commence la période renouvellement
des beaux au mois de mars c'est en
moyenne près d'un animal par jour qui a
abandonné pour cause de déménagement à
la spéciale Montréal au Québec 25% des
propriétaires acceptent des animaux ce
taux grimpe à 65% pour ceux qui
acceptent uniquement les chats beaucoup
de locataires qui ne souhaitent pas être
incommodée par la présence d'animaux
alors on voit vraiment
remettre sur les épaules des
propriétaires d'avoir d'arbitrer les
conflits entre locataire on va pas ça
comme un enjeu puisqu'il existe déjà des
recours sur place pour répondre à ces
enjeux
d'ici là Charlotte Gagnon guerre
d'espoir de trouver un logement dans son
quartier où elle pourra continuer à
vivre avec Milou avec moi j'espère ne
pas me retrouver sans appartement en
premier juillet ici Daniel cadjo
Radio-Canada montré